tunis mobilisés contre la répression
policière
ce samedi ils étaient plusieurs milliers
à s'être rassemblés dans la capitale
tunisienne à l'appel de différents
syndicats les manifestants pointe du
doigt les violences policières constaté
depuis plusieurs semaines dans le pays
par mieux union générale tunisienne du
travail premier syndicat à l'échelle
nationale pour la première fois depuis
le réveil de la mobilisation en tunisie
lui gtt a tenu à soutenir la
manifestation
aujourd'hui c'est un cri d'alarmé pour
défendre la révolution pour protéger des
libertés menacées
malgré une forte présence policière dans
le centre ville de tunis ce
rassemblement est le plus important
depuis des années dans le viseur des
manifestants le parti ennahdha qu'il
juge responsable de la crise dans
laquelle est plongée le pays pour de
nombreux tunisiens
une crainte grandit celle de subir une
remise en cause des acquis obtenus il ya
dix ans lors de la révolution de jasmin
on est là parce qu on en a marre
parce qu'on en a marre de la corruption
ne m'embarque du vol on en a marre de
cette pseudo élite politique qui ne fait
que
que corps entre le pays nouveau les
arrêter les jeunes elle est maltraité et
torturé il est encore des tortures
maintenant il ya des manifestants qui se
font arrêter de ces oeufs pour un statut
facebook
c'est important parce que c'est la
première fois depuis le 11 janvier qu'on
est debout se regroupent et
indépendamment de nos deux mondes
indépendamment de nos attentes on est
tous là pour dire qu'on n'est pas on est
pro n'est pas satisfait et on est au
delà de tout ce qu'ils ont pu faire
pendant ces dix ans je représente des
jeunes de ma génération
salut responsabilité nationale il faut
qu'on le fasse tout ça soit fait c'est
assez dommage qu'on en arrive là
la jeunesse tunisienne une autre
priorité pour ces manifestants il
réclame la libération de tous les jeunes
arrêtés depuis le 14 janvier dernier
selon la ligue tunisienne pour la
défense des droits de l'homme
il y aurait eu plus de 1500 arrestations
ces dernières semaines les manifestants
restent déterminés à poursuivre leur
mouvement tant que le gouvernement ne
répondra pas à leurs revendications